décidément l'épouvanté est à la mode en
ce moment après jusqu'à l'aube sur
netflix c'est m6 qui prépare une
nouvelle émission d'horreur et de
frissons le concept proposé à des
candidats de passer deux jours et une
nuit dans un des châteaux les plus
lentes et de france si la chaîne n'a pas
encore donné le nom du château en
question sachez que pour les amateurs de
peur le casting est encore loin d'être
terminé et qu'une rémunération sera à la
clé pour les aventuriers choisi en
croire laurence boccolini ce concept ne
serait pas tout à fait nouveau comme l'a
révélé animatrice avec un coup de gueule
sur twitter ce sera bien plus facile
pour m6 de le faire que pour moi oui
en 2007 tout le monde a claqué la porte
au nez de mon projet qui était le même
bonne chance à vous alors à noter que
pour son casting m6 recherche
principalement des duo mère-fille couple
frères et soeurs ou simplement deux amis
alors avis aux amateurs de faire perdre
six mairies etc
le but en 2 d'avoir peur alors j'ai
quand même une info vous donner c'est
que moi j'avais fait un sujet sur la
maison de l'amitié il savait le film
fait le box pour m6 si on devait
détourner à la maison je vous jure c'est
vrai que coppola les équipes se sont
rapprochés de cette maison et sont
entrées dans les maisons
ils n'ont pas tomber dedans tellement il
était mal donc moi j'y crois un peu
encore faut-il trouver croyez à quoi ma
chérie je vous dis je rêvais d'y
participer avec avec benoît alors qu'on
en avait parlé de moi mais de bonne
compagnie on en avait parlé la semaine
dernière on avait quand même des petits
doutes sur ce genre d'émission mais je
sais pas pourquoi je me dis que m6 en
effet peuvent nous surprendre et nous
faire frissonner il ya des châteaux
hantés en france très connu oui enfin
comme de l'ucij pas si vous connaissez
oui mais ça c'est pas des blagues et
puisque mieux le jeu vous arrêter aussi
le fond tu oublies la cote à la pâte et
oui
mais faites vous suivre permet d'envoyer
un mail vous jure que c'est vrai et voir
quelqu'un j'ai vu une émission le
fantôme il y avait des caméras et la
haie ou comme ça ça donne quoi
moi j'ai très peur de sa base ça
m'apparaîtrait peut écouter les manuels
jauger la musau par les détonations des
sociétés contre château des bogdanov qui
est à vendre et ce genre de programme on
tombe elle était facile à dire que
michel drucker vous avez bien sûr ce lot
alors oui ce genre de programme sur le
papier effectivement c'est très
intéressant mais c'est une question de
moyens aussi qu'ils seront vivaces eux
contre moi programme de netflix jusqu'à
l'aube où on se demande ce que ce que
fout ce programme en fait ce sont juste
des gens qui sont peur entre eux la m6
va droit dans le mur si effectivement il
ya des vrais moyens un vrai décor des
vrais parce que forcément il ya des
vrais vendus aux ischios des vrais
fantômes voilà il ya la famille est
bondée et cette désaffectation aussi une
production mis sur ce genre de parra
l'accastillage un château hanté au bcg
ma mère le bois j'aime bien l'idée qu'on
verra mais j'adore si on y croit
franchement si on y croient ils tout ce
qui paraît normal ça marche très bien
cette vision mais j'ai dit non à vous de
penser comme ça maintenant car était
bien entonner ce qui fait peur c'est
formidable je sais pas quoi dire là sur
elle
lui est des pros il est des pros de
trois émissions maintenant il va devenir
comment vous pourriez participer
j'ai très peur j'ai j'y crois moi là
j'ai pas du tout envie des mois j'ai vu
traverser un gain un guéridon chez moi
comme ça et tout est de plus les plombs
ont sauté je rigole pas du tout avec ça